le projet de loi initial propose
plusieurs mesures d'accompagnement
estimer à 5,9 milliards d'euros en 2030
année prévu pour l'équilibre du système
mais ce retour à l'équilibre est
fragilisé par les amendements du
Gouvernement déposés en première lecture
à l'Assemblée nationale estimée à 800
millions à l'horizon 2030
vigilance sur ce point la réforme est
prévoit également qu'à compter du 1er
septembre 2023 les régimes des retraites
des industries électriques et gazières
de la RATP de la Banque de France
d'éclairs et employés de notaire et des
élus du Conseil économique social et
environnemental naphilippe plus de
nouveaux cotisants ces régimes sont
actuellement équilibrés soit au moyen
d'une taxe spéciale soit au moyen d'une
subvention d'équilibre versée par l'État
soit structurellement déficitaire le
montant des cotisations ne couvrant pas
celui des pensions
la fermeture de ces régimes entraînera
mécaniquement une attrition du nombre de
cotisants pour les caisses concernées je
m'étonne que les conséquences
financières ne soient pas d'ores et déjà
prévues notamment le reversement par la
CNAV et l'agirco des cotisants des
cotisations des nouveaux affiliés à
l'instar de ce qui fonctionne pour la
SNCF le relèvement de l'âge d'ouverture
des droits de deux ans concernent
également tous les agents de la fonction
publique il ne devrait avoir que peu
d'effets car l'âge de départ est déjà de
63 ans et 8 mois pour laisser dentaires
et 60 ans pour les actifs le solde
technique du compte d'affectation
spéciale pension pourrait être de 0,7
milliards d'euros en 2027 puis 1,1
milliard d'euros en 2030 de nouveau je
préconise une immobilisation de ces
excédents au sein du Fonds de réserve
des retraites afin de garantir l'avenir
des retraites publics
[Musique]